I don't believe in fairytales about
chakras or energy or the power of belief
you wonder what I see in your future
possibility this film is amazing I know
you were influenced a lot by Steve
Ditko's art I'm curious what other
influences went into some of these
incredible visual sequences the other
dimensions I mean the did Co art was the
most influential thing I mean I looked
at a lot of proper arts and Usher and
Dali and the kind of usual suspects that
German Expressionism anything in cinema
where physical or visual effects were
being used for something other than just
destructiveness but for expression for
visual design I always felt like the
matrix and Inception you know these were
movies that would come along and do
things that were new and we're
surprising because they were giving you
visceral visual experiences that he
hadn't had in a cinema before and I
wanted this to be one of those movies
you have a look that is not unlike
Doctor Strange did you have any
manscaping tips for Benedict Cumberbatch
I just told him he's gonna have to have
a goatee in this movie because that's
Doctor Strange you know and he seemed
okay with it but I fancy that when he
shapes in the movie and looks at himself
what he's really is thinking is like the
director
be careful which pests who travel
downstream stronger men than you have
bust their way
do you feel pressure adapting this and
had it to do with that I didn't feel
pressure except for the pressure that I
felt as a fan you know I mean I'm such a
marble fan and such a comic book fan and
I felt the need for some freshness and
some newness and some wild innovation
and you know that that comic book movies
need to evolve or they're going to die
they're gonna die out and and that's
true of any genre and and this just felt
like a good evolutionary step if you
could steal sling ring cloak of
levitation
I've agamotto what would you take home
with you the eye bag omona i do have the
eye of agamotto by the way I took it
from the set are you serious that's in
my house so that's mine
I told ya hearing through time
looking for you